Hello everybody and welcome back. I am
your host of the series Google software
engineer Jordan. Uh I am actually known
as the best back-end developer in the
world due to the sheer size and
gravitational force of my ass. And of
course I'm wellversed in git all
commands with the exception of git
pulling. If you were here for the last
video, you know that we started to go
into what database indexes are. And in
today's video I'll be covering one
specific type known as hash indexes. So
without wasting any more of your time,
let me go ahead and grab the iPad and we
can start scribbling. All right, welcome
back everybody. Let's go ahead and get
started. So to review from last video,
we talked about indexes in general and
why we might need them. So in that case,
there's going to be two reasons. Here's
number one. The first one is O of N
reads.
So O of N reads basically means that uh
effectively it ties into reason number
two. we have to go through all database
rows through all rows to find the rows
that we want. Which means if we have
some sort of table and here are all my
rows in it every single time if I want
to find all rows for example where the
name is Jordan or the ID is 10 or
anything like that I have to go through
every single one and that is O of end
time complexity and so that is kind of
the backdrop of this entire lesson made
pretty simple. So, let's go over a
different type of index effectively that
is going to act as a precursor for the
other indexes that we're going to go
over and we're going to see the pros and
cons of this one. So, today's video is
about hash indexes. Makes me think of
hash browns cuz I'm fat. But let's go
into this further. Okay, so let's review
a hashmap because of course hash indexes
are actually going and based off a
hashmap. So, the first thing to talk
about when we talk about a hashmap is a
hash function. So a hash function is
effectively this. It is a black box,
right? We have no clue what's going on
in there. But all we know is that out of
all uh the elements that we could pass
into it, you know, let's say I'm passing
in Jordan,
what it's going to spit out is a number.
Obviously, hash functions can spit out
anything, but we know that whenever we
pass in Jordan, it's always going to
spit out some number. Let's say that
number is four. And so this hash
function, it's always going to spit out
the same number from this domain to the
range where let's say the range that it
could possibly spit out is 0 to 10. And
so Jordan is always going to return a
four. Uh, you know, let's say we put in
apple, that's going to return uh, who
knows, a six or something like that. And
of course, it is possible that sometimes
I'll do another word and it's also going
to return a four, right? Let's uh, we'll
do shack just to keep things consistent
with last video. you know we get unlucky
that also happens to return a four. So
basically the premise of a hashmap is
that we have our hash function h and
when we take in the the key and the
value that we want we basically take h
of key and that's going to return some
value v. We put it at basically the
index v of the array. So in the previous
example let's imagine we have this array
with uh indexes 0 through 9, right? It's
size 10. And our hash function can
return anywhere from 0 to 10. In the
event of the hashmap, basically what I'd
be doing is I'd be putting Jordan
at index 4, right? And so this allows us
to have O of one uh or constant time
reads and writes. The reason for this
being that our hash function is going to
take constant time and basically then we
can jump over to this place in memory,
which is really really great. So we jump
right over here and that is O of one to
be able to access our element Jordan
check if it's in the hashmap etc etc
etc. This is more of a hash set just
since I haven't um you know added like a
corresponding value to Jordan but don't
worry about that for now who cares. Um
and then you know the the other thing to
consider is that sometimes like I said
you know Shaq for example would also uh
be hashed to the same place. So what do
we do if two things are hashed to the
same box right you know now we have
Jordan and Shaq. Well, there's a couple
ways of actually uh dealing with this.
One is where instead of just putting the
key here, you would actually have a
linked list, right? So, I would have a
node that contains Jordan and then a
node containing Shack. That's called
chaining.
And then the other alternative is
probing, right? Where I would just look
for the next available spot in the
hashmap. So, for example, that would be
this one here. And then Shaq would be
placed in this box of the array. Uh yes,
obviously that does ruin the kind of
constant time complexity of it, but uh
if you do some math using advertised
time complexity and uh something called
a load factor, you can basically uh
prove that it is still on average
constant time. And uh you know, I'm not
going to get into that for this video. I
have a dedicated video to this. But you
know, that's generally how something
like a hashmap would work. So let's
continue to scroll down. So we have our
hashmap, right?
And the general kind of gist of a hash
index is just literally use a hashmap,
right? So we know that the point of an
index is we want to easily be able to
scan for a certain key.
So in the case of you know uh Jordan for
instance, I would basically put in the
hashmap Jordan as the key and then the
value corresponding to it would be the
place on disk. who knows what address it
would be or possibly even the actual row
itself. Um, but then that's what's in
the hashmap. You know, you could do the
same thing with Shaq. And, you know, to
keep the example uh from last time, you
could do the same thing with Donald,
right?
Should all make sense for uh the most
part? Whatever. Let's assume those are
addresses on disc. Who knows? They're
probably not. Uh, but yes, that's the
point. We have our hashmap that maps
keys and values of basically the index
key that we care about and then the
actual location on disk of the row. And
so this is going to be zero of one to
actually find a row when we're searching
by uh the name. And that's in both reads
and writes,
right? Because we can just go right to
the row and update it too, which is
perfect. However, there are some pretty
big issues with the hashmap. So the
first one is that hashmaps
are bad on disk.
So the reason that they're bad on disk
is this is now going to be the third
episode out of three that I've drawn
this. We have our wheel and we have our
pointer in a hashmap. The values that
you care about are stored all over that
array, right? I might have one here.
might have one here, might have one in
the middle because the entire point of
the hashing function is to distribute
elements evenly.
And so what that means is that on disk
we also have elements distributed
equally because disk is effectively just
that big array, right? You know, 1 2 3
etc etc. So the performance is actually
pretty poor on hashmaps because we're
jumping around all over this metallic uh
disc and as a result it just doesn't
work very well. So what that means is
that hash indexes
are always kept in memory.
But this has a couple of other issues.
One is that memory is expensive. I'm
going to say RAM instead of memory. RAM
is expensive.
So there's less of it.
And because there's less, it means that
we actually have less leeway in terms of
putting data in our database because all
of our keys at the end of the day have
to fit in RAM.
So that's basically one issue, right?
That's kind of the fundamental trade-off
that we're making here. Obviously, hash
indexes are going to be super fast,
right? All the operations are O of one.
Uh, and it's also in memory, which is
even faster than disk. Random access
memory means you can just jump around
super quickly. That's the entire point.
You're doing random accesses all over
this array. So that's great. But there
are still more downsides to having
everything in memory because if we
recall, RAM is not durable.
And for our database, it would be pretty
terrible if we could just lose data all
the time. That wouldn't work very well
for us at all, would it? So basically
now what we need to do is figure out a
way of actually keeping our data.
Because if our computer were to shut
down, our entire contents of our
database would be lost. And the way that
we're going to do this is with this a
write ahead log.
So I haven't really gone into this topic
yet, but it is pretty similar to
something that I showed last episode
where imagine a write ahead log as
literally just a list every single time
of all the writes and updates that
you're making to the database. So for
example, one thing could be, you know,
change size of row, you know, with
Jordan
to 10,
something like that. And so we write
down all the changes that we're making
in the database. And the write ahead log
is actually stored on disk. It's
completely writing sequentially on disk,
right? So this is literally right next
to this line, which is next to this
line. And so since those lines are next
to each other, these writes are
relatively fast. We're still doing
sequential writes which are not bad on a
hard drive. So because we're using this
write ahead log now we have durability.
And so if the computer ever dies and we
needed to actually recreate our hash
index, we could do so by replaying all
those changes in the write ahead log.
First we would replay this one, then we
would replay this one, then we would
replay this one. And so that way we
could repopulate the hash index.
And so that is how our write ahead log
provides durability. This is not
something that's only used in the hash
index. It's actually used in multiple
different types of indexes, but we will
cover that in future videos. So that's
how we would repopulate the hash index.
So even though uh the hash index is
itself kept in memory, having the write
ahead log is going to slow things down
because disk writes are definitely going
to be slower than memory writes even
though it is an O of one time
complexity, right? Because we're writing
sequentially. Okay, so what's our last
problem?
We have this hash index. We know we have
to write to disk first if we want
durability. If we don't care, sure, it's
effectively just a hashmap in memory.
Our last problem is that we can't do
range queries.
Why can't we do range queries? Well,
think about how hashmaps work. Last time
I introduced the problem of a range
query as let's say we want all rows with
names between
A and B.
Uh with names
between A and B. So what the hashmap is
really good for is we can easily check
basically
you know Alex
uh Abe
and Allen we can easily check if the key
Alex is in the hashmap right that's O of
one but for us to actually check all the
rows with names between A and B we would
have to literally loop through every
single possible name between A and B and
check if that's in the hashmap, which is
not feasible. There are infinite names
between A and B, you know, if we're not
just like, you know, sticking to actual
names that exist on the Earth. So, we
would have to check literally every
possible string, and again, there are
infinite of those. So, that doesn't work
very well. That's why this isn't really
feasible for range queries because the
only way to do a range query with a
hashmap is to either iterate through all
the indexes which again is O of N or to
literally check all of the possibilities
uh between A and B which in some cases
is endless. Right? So O of N is probably
what we would stick with. We would just
go through all the indexes in the array
and check if it fits our predicate. Um
but again this is useless to us because
we've already said ON reads are not good
enough for us. So we're going to need a
better solution in the future. Um some
of you may be thinking use something
like uh a tree set, right? Uh you
remember binary search trees. Binary
search trees are very nice because uh
you know you're able to actually perform
range queries really easily because the
kind of invariance of the binary search
tree means that let's say you know we
want everything between uh whatever this
node and this node is. You know, I'm not
explaining this well, but whatever.
Point is, binary search trees work much
better in terms of doing range queries.
You can actually do them. However,
unlike with a hash index, uh, reads and
writes are going to be O of login, which
is worse than our hash index, right?
Where everything was O of one. So,
basically, in conclusion, hash indexes
are really, really great if you want to
do O of one reads and O of one writes,
but you don't need range queries. And
additionally, it comes with the even
further constraint that you basically
have to keep all of your keys in memory.
So if you do have a sufficiently small
data set and it's something that you're
willing to tolerate where you're not
looking for range queries, but you're
mostly just looking to get one row at a
time, then the hash index could be for
you. So keep this in mind, guys. Um, you
know, as we move on through the indexes,
um, there are obviously going to be
trade-offs between all three, but these
are kind of the main pros and cons of
the hash index.